hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new beast studio buds and today we
will be comparing it to the airpods pro
and the airpods 2 to see is it worth
spending the extra money
or how much of an upgrade is it if you
already have airpods
and we're not only going to compare the
sound quality and features but also
things like
active noise cancellation transparency
mode microphone quality
comfort and more now as i get these out
of the box let's talk about prices these
come in at 150 bucks
which seem cheap for beats now of course
the airpods 2 with the wireless charging
case
comes in at 200 but you can now get
those for about 160
and airpods pro you can get them as low
as 190
right now instead of 250. we'll leave
links down in the video description for
the best prices to
all of these so at those prices it makes
these new ones
maybe a little bit of a tougher sell
than what you initially
look at with the msrp prices now i got
the case out of the box
it does seem a little bit larger than i
expected
does also have some weight to it so if
we compare it to the airpods
pro case it is longer is also
taller and it does seem like it's a
little bit thicker as well and the
difference is even bigger if you own
the original air pods those are even
smaller and thinner
than the airpods pro let's do a quick
pocket test
shove these in all right i definitely
feel them and these pants are a little
bit tighter
and let's see if they can fit into the
pocket watch
pocket no well got them in it is a
little bit tight
definitely better than some other
alternatives but not as good
as these yeah the airpods pro definitely
seemed thinner you could tell now one
cool thing is that beats is finally
starting to use usb
type-c instead of lightning so it is
more universal i really like that and
one thing i have to point out
is just how cheap this case
feels and looks you actually can see the
seam
of the plastic when it was injected
molded right in here
that is interesting for a beats product
or a product by
apple you could tell that this is a
budget product
but the case itself feels like a case
for maybe a pair of 50 dollar wireless
headphones and another way you could
tell these are budget earbuds is the
fact that there's no wireless charging
like you have
with these other two now if you don't
need wireless charging
instead of 160 you could probably pick
these up for about 109 with our link
below now i use wireless charging all
the time for my earbuds let me know if
you guys actually care about that or not
now there's one thing that i was really
excited for
with the new beats studio buds and now
that it looked further
into it they are being kind of sneaky
and that is the battery life these
things are rated for
eight hours and i was thinking man eight
hours with active noise cancellation
that's amazing
the airpods pro they're rated 4.5 hours
and of course the airpods don't have
that they're rated for five hours
without it
but when you look further into it if you
enable the active noise cancellation you
go from eight hours
down to five hours so you lose three
hours right there
compared to going from five hours to 4.5
with the airpods pro now the same thing
goes with the case both airpods are
rated over 24 hours
with the case included that's with
active noise cancellation on the pros
and with the beats studio modes you go
from
24 hours down to 15 with active noise
cancellation so no
these are not battery life monsters now
you also don't get the h1 chip and we'll
talk about the limitations without it in
just a bit
but let's go ahead and pop it open and i
want to see if we still get that pop up
yes we do beats studio buds let's hit
connect so you can still pair it
very easily now let's go ahead and pull
one of these out
okay that is actually a very strong
magnet i was not expecting that
wow okay i don't think i've ever felt
magnets that powerful
and look at that this is pretty small
this is one thing that intrigued me with
the beats
just how compact it is and of course we
don't have that long
stem so barely anything sticks out of
your ears and a lot of
third-party alternatives if they don't
have a stem
they have a really big bud a lot of
stuff that's sticking out so
i'm excited to hear how they sound and
also have the microphones
pick up without that stem see how the
sound quality compares
let's go ahead and put these in my ears
i made sure to have it in
off mode here so i'm not going to hear
the noise cancellation
just yet so they do stick out a little
bit but not that much and one other
interesting thing is
for the controls there are actually
buttons on these it's not a touch
surface now that could be a good thing
if you want to be more reliable
but when i press in it actually pushes
the butt in my ear more so so i guess
it's a win or lose now i'm going to pull
these out
i'm going to put my air pod pros in and
one thing i absolutely love about the
airpod pros
is on the stem you actually have the
surface that you press and you hear an
audible click
now for controls this is my all-time
favorite it's reliable it is very easy
with the original airpods if you guys
have these you actually have to just tap
on
the surface itself it's fairly reliable
but it's the same kind of thing where
you're pushing it into your ear more and
then sometimes it won't pick up so i
have to redo
the command and now let's talk about
comfort
surprisingly these don't seal in my ears
as much as i expected i'm not getting a
super you know plugged ear type of feel
that i would with some other
alternatives but of course you still get
a little bit of that and i don't know if
apple maybe changed the design a little
bit to reduce that
but with the airpods pro they actually
have this vent so when you pop them in
you actually feel a plugged ear kind of
a feel and all of a sudden you
feel like this little release and it
releases the pressure and it makes it
feel
more like earbuds that don't seal in
your ears but of course
the original air airpods as long as they
fit your ears these are the most
comfortable they don't go into your ear
canal they just sit there and rest
and you don't get that kind of a plugged
feeling now of course i will be talking
about long-term comfort in my full
review so if you guys want to see that
make sure you guys are subscribed
that also will help us reach our goal of
1 million subscribers before the end
of the year that would be awesome
now let's go ahead and talk about active
noise cancellation
this is something that most new
headphones especially higher end ones
have to have
i'm gonna start out with the airpods pro
i mean i use these pretty much
every single day bam the active noise
cancellation kicked in
my ears don't feel plugged and that ac
is on right now it's super hot outside
most of it is gone most that sound is
gone just the higher end kind of
vent noise the air coming through the
vents i can hear but the low end rumble
is all gone
it's not the best noise reduction the
new sony's that are more expensive those
are definitely better
but they do do a good job now this is
the moment of truth we know the original
airpods don't block anything out at all
let's try these out
and you know what just even without the
active noise cancellation
uh turned on these are blocking out more
so than the airpods without active noise
cancellation turned on
not as much as with it on but just
because there's no vent there
and maybe these ear tips might also be
bigger i know apple said they redesigned
them
now moment of truth let's go ahead and
enable active noise cancellation
okay whoa my voice got higher
that is that is weird my voice
uh i still hear it but the low one got
taken out let me let me take listen to
that vent
all right guys this is this is crazy um
so this is taking out more of the low
end
rumble than the airpod pro not as much
of the high end i hear the high end
wind coming out a little bit louder but
that low end it is taking
more out than the airpods pro and that's
probably why the low end of my voice is
gone too where it isn't with the airpods
pro
now the next thing is the transparency
mode that is something that
really matters to me airpods pro are the
best earbuds in the market for
transparency mode it literally sounds
almost like not having anything in that
van sounds so natural my voice and jocko
had to say something
hey what's up you sound exactly natural
all right this is where i think
these uh beats are not going to be able
to compare
huh okay and jack go ahead and say
something
i mean you sound natural but you sound
much quieter and that vent sounds
slightly staticky and my voice sounds
like
i'm much quieter than i actually am it
sounds nothing like the airpod pro this
is
a huge difference i honestly did not
expect these to be this bad in
transparency mode and that has me
wondering
are the microphones just as terrible as
that transparency mode
so let's go ahead and pop these in and
we'll compare the microphones between
the original airpods or the airpods 2
the pros and these new beats this is the
microphone quality that you can expect
from apple's
air pods too and this is the microphone
quality they can expect from the beats
studio buds in a room with some hvac
noise
and this is the microphone quality with
apple's air pods pro
in a room that has a fair bit of hvac
noise
and now let's finally compare the sound
quality i am super excited to hear these
out
we are gonna start out with our classic
iconic max tech song that you guys
begged us to bring back we're gonna
start out with that and we're gonna
start out with
the air pods now i'm gonna go ahead and
listen to all three you guys will see a
super cut
of that you guys can hear the song along
with me
and i haven't listened to these in a
while so i'm excited to hear these
as well i remember they were super loud
[Music]
all right guys well wow
first off yes the airpods get loud and
they have to because they don't seal
into your ear if there's outside noise
it has to combat that which i love loud
earbuds
but it's not good for your ears i have
tinnitus already
airpods pro definitely sound better
quality
but surprisingly the bass isn't as deep
as earpods the highs are a lot better
mids are also better now these the new
beats first thing i noticed in the
vocals they're not as
bright they're not as clear
as sounding that was first a
disappointment but then when the bass
kicked in
man the bass goes deep it sounds good
definitely these are beats earbuds i
really liked how it sounded in this song
i did wish for a little bit more highs
though so let's go ahead
and flip over to our second track this
song has a bunch of instrumentals has
some
lower bass some highs it's a really good
track for hearing
um the sound stage there are some sweeps
in there so let's go ahead and take a
listen
[Music]
all right well that was very interesting
of course
bass you got a ton of it a lot of bass
is
deep it sounds good it is a little
overpowering though and the highs
that just sounded surprisingly good they
sounded accurate
i would like to eq these honestly with
the other ones
i like airpod pros i like the balance
sound bass is a little bit too
substantial
and then the highs need to be pushed up
a little bit and with the
beats app it does not let you do it so
if you're using spotify you can go in
there and do some tweaks in there
but there's no system-wide eq for these
but surprisingly it sounded good there
was no distortion there at the end when
we had the sweep with other instruments
coming in
with the air pods the two at full volume
there was a little bit of distortion
airpods pro was great
i do wish that the beats gave us a
little bit more volume not that you need
it because the seal is so good
just because i like my music loud but
overall that was good
let's go ahead and switch over to the
last track this is where these beats
could fall apart if they're not able to
distinguish between the different
instruments that are there
of course we're choosing a song so that
you guys can listen along with us if we
chose other music you guys wouldn't be
able to because of copyright
so let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
is
all right okay another surprise
wow those those did a lot better i will
say
airpods 2 sucked i was listening this
song
it sounded terrible uh with rock when
you have all those instruments you have
the synth in the background
the synth was getting lost vocals are
getting blended it sounded harsh
this rock by far just does not sound
good with these a lot better
with the airpods pro very well balanced
i could hear the separation of
instruments
uh no distortion or anything sounded way
better
but man the beats on the other hand i
thought these are going to do terrible
i do wish that the highs were a little
bit more colored but other than that the
base was
tight i thought it would be maybe a
little bit i don't know just
overpowering
but with the drums there different
layers of drums
it sounded great and i could still hear
the synth in the background and the
vocals so as far as different
instruments
they were not being blended together and
i did appreciate the extra bass there so
for rock these are the best i was
honestly surprised by
how well they did now another thing that
angelica pointed out to me
is that with the beats you said you
couldn't hear anything at all
even with this last track no nothing
okay so
with the air pods you hear a ton right
everything you can hear
and you're about what six feet away from
me or so with the airpods pro you still
hear a lot right
you hear it but the beats you hear
nothing well i guess that makes sense if
there's no
valve to get the pressure out and they
seal in very well
i did swap to the larger ear tips before
i did the music test
and the active noise cancellation test
yeah so if you don't want people to hear
your music
um that's another bonus and of course
they do not get as loud as the airpods
pro
probably about on par with things you
know headphones like the galaxy buds or
the new sony xm4s
so overall what is my verdict well
i don't know how the microphone sound
you guys heard that so make sure you
guys commented below i haven't heard
that yet
but as far as sound quality it is better
than i expected and if the bass is a
little bit too strong in some genres you
can always turn that down
in a lot of different apps you can kick
the highs up but they are
fairly accurate there's some good
separation of instruments i was not
expecting that
not a lot of sound leakage the active
noise cancellation was better than i
expected as well
ambient mode sucks build quality is not
good
but they're brand new for 150 bucks i'm
sure in the future the price will go
down and once again they're linked
down below so they did better than i
expected i wish they had wireless
charging
i know if i switch over to using these
i'm gonna definitely miss that but at
least it has usb
type c so which one would i buy
if these are 250 and these are 150
i would go for these now i still have to
test long-term comfort
that'll be in the review but at 190
versus um 150 that makes it a tougher
choice
with these airpods you do have the h1
chip so they are going to switch
instantly to other devices as you pick
them up or if you get a phone call on
your phone it'll switch instantly
you have the icloud pairing which is
nice if you're connecting and watching
movies you're going to get the spatial
audio and the atmos sound which is great
so you have a lot of extra features with
these software features that you don't
get
with the beats but if you don't care
about that and you care about money and
you like
more bass these beats actually exceeded
my
expectations so there you guys go let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section
below hit that subscribe button above if
you guys want to help us reach a million
subscribers before the end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it check out
those videos right over there this has
been max and i'll see you
in the next video
you